I was real angry because he they told me
I I had to not sing or in my face some
surgery so I had to cancel the tour
never done that in my entire career and
it's very frustrating cuz we were in
grow up so you've that part around the
world and you gotta call it off and go
home
now that josh has recovered from his
house scare the boys are back on the
road for their 80s inspired Marianas
Trench and the Last Crusade tour part of
the way we're doing the show right now
is very we're going for that like 80s
Sunset Strip type of vibe so it's pretty
flashy a little over the top but hey so
much fans have been patiently awaiting
for these concert dates even though many
of them have seen the band before fans
that have come to 30 40 50 60 shows that
is crazy like I had bands that have
loved but I've seen them like two or
three times maybe I never liked to been
there yeah Canadian rockers have been
doing this for a decade they're still
amazed by what they've accomplished
we've just had this kind of quiet
rolling momentum for 10 years and that's
that's a great way to do it cuz it keeps
you humble and it gives you grateful